la pologne le père ubu d'alfred jarry
avec son affreuse humour disait que le
grand drame de cette nation souffrante
était qu'il y eut des polonais alors
qu'il n'y avait pas de pologne vous père
ubu se trompait il y a toujours une
pologne
même et surtout quand elles n'existaient
plus que dans le coeur des polonais
aujourd'hui il se trouve simplement qu'à
la suite d'une sorte de glissement
géographique consécutif à l'effondrement
du reich hitlérien
elle s'est déplacé d'environ 200
kilomètres vers l'ouest de l'europe et
recouvre en partie des territoires
autrefois germanique pour le voyageur
qui prend la voie maritime
elle commence au nord ouest as tétine
qui vient nous proposer l'enchevêtrement
de ces grues et la masse ankylosé de son
hôtel moderne
une belle route droite mène le voyageur
à poznan
célèbre pour son musée d'instruments à
cordes car la pologne
parfois ce n'est plus qu'un souvenir
réfugiés dans le ciel obscur de la
musique
mais n'oubliez pas que nous ne disposons
que d'une dizaine de minutes pour
traverser le pays du nord au sud
et voici
franck l'a autrefois breizh là-haut en
silésie avec sa cathédrale son hôtel de
ville ses vieilles rues c'est tour et
dont on apprend avec étonnement qu'elle
n'était plus après la dernière guerre
qu'un champ de ruines où la population
était tombé de 600 milles à 30000
habitants
une à une les pierres ont repris leur
place jusqu'au sommet de la plus haute
tour les trente mille sont aujourd'hui
400 milles les châteaux les églises
reconstituer abrite des musées des
écoles wroclaw oubliant breizh là haut
est redevenu broc lave et à travers les
vallons boisés d'alentour au pied des
grands châteaux sa grande école
d'équitation perpétue le souvenir de
l'illustre cavalerie polonaise lancé
naguère sous le commandement du
désespoir et la seule protection de
l'honneur entre le poitrail de faire des
divisions allemandes
m
non
quel peuple aura aussi souvent quand
battu non pour sauver une ville ou une
province non pour rectifier le dessin
d'une frontière mais pour se re
conquérir lui-même et obtenir enfin de
l'histoire le droit d'exister
m
mais nous ne nous attarderons pas plu à
wroclaw cap aux hommes mais est est in
cracovie nous attend dans un
environnement de brume qui donne sa
masse architecturale impressionnante une
légèreté drège
l'ancienne capitale des rois de pologne
la plus riche des villes d'art polonaise
est elle en train de se dissoudre ou au
contraire de renaître comme une image
qui peu à peu se reforme au fond de la
mémoire
elle aussi aurait pu disparaître elle
aussi se trouvait dans laxe du drang
marc austen couverte est recouverte par
le flux et le reflux des armées en
campagne elle aussi pouvait être
détruite
ces bureaux ray été rebâti ces maisons
reconstruites c'est tout redresser mais
que serait devenu ce qu'elle a de plus
précieux et plus fragile que les autres
ces vitraux ses fresques médiévales ses
dentelles baran
ouais
une offensive inopinée des armées
soviétiques lors à sauver l'évacuation
avait commencé avant qu'on parvienne à
la défense leucan l'ordre sempiternel du
haut commandement de la débâcle
ne cédez pas un millimètre de terrain la
victoire ou la mort ainsi cracovie a
vécu sans avoir à revivre
événement rare en pologne de l'autre
côté de ce barrage symbolique dans le
rideau fracassant semble séparer le
passé artistique du présent industriels
il y a une autre pologne qui n'est pas
l'immense plaine frissonnante au clair
de lune quelle imagination se représente
lorsqu'on lui parle du pays chopin mais
une région de rochers abrupts de gorge
de montagne a reparlé coupante où le
décor déformé par une vieille colère
tellurique suspens une sorte de menace
inattendue sur la paie des lacs et des
vallées le père ubu est plus en plus
tort il y a plusieurs pologne
à
mes anciennes ou modernes
traditionalistes ou futuriste tout l'est
pologne que l'on rencontre en pologne
ont au moins un point commun un amour de
l'art directement issu d'un respect de
la nature qui s'étend à toutes les
créatures du bon dieu qu'ailleurs on se
fait un devoir quand ce n'est pas un
sinistre plaisir de massacrer il y a
encore des loups campo leur et des ours
qu'on ne cherche pas plus à détruire
qu'à réduire à l'état faure 1
tu es le seul pays d'europe où l'on
rencontre encore façon de parler des
élans et des bisons comme on n'en voit
plus ailleurs que sous la forme
décoratives des peintures rupestres
et
et l'on a parfois la chance d'apercevoir
le long des forêts blanche et noire
la fugue échevelé des tarpans qu'un
rayon de soleil un orage lointain un
souffle de vent un reflet sur l'eau
relance ou arrêtent l'oreille dresser un
sabour en l'air comme un doigt levé qui
hésitent au bout du clavier
tarpon on connaissait ce sont des choses
autrefois domestique revenu à la liberté
par le retour à l'état de nature
un rêve pour l'homme civilisé
pologne admirable pays sur lequel traîne
une musique